et
je suis arrivé dans la filière canne en
2005 donc travaillé à la soirée le bois
rouge et en juin 2010 j'intégrais le
centre technique en tant que responsable
relation client le centre technique
interprofessionnel de la canne et du
sucre a été créée en 1952 donc c'est un
établissement d'utilité publique elle a
pour mission principale la mesure de la
richesse de la canne les vrais par
environ 3500 planteurs donc sur les deux
sucreries le bollénois
technique à d'autres activités en
parallèle donc le développement agricole
le scg
l'expérimentation et des améliorations
foncières donc nous sommes 38 personnes
permanentes anciennes techniques et 65
saisonniers pendant 50 ans du camp
pendant la campagne sucrière ma mission
consiste à garantir à veiller à la
sincérité et à la neutralité des mesures
effectuées par le cic s sur le processus
de la mesure de la richesse
via un protocole de campagne
durant l'intercampagne je m'occupe du
développement agricole donc j'ai une
équipe de 14 techniciens
agricoles ou via les pôles cannes donc
ils sont six les techniciens ont pour
mission d'apporter un appui technique et
logistique aux planteurs dans le montage
de leur dossier de replantation
le projet dont je suis fier au cti csc
l'installation des ordinateurs embarqués
au niveau des sondes donc en 2010 et en
2011 pour l'intégralité des sondes donc
me
le but principal aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir vraiment une traçabilité de
toutes les analyses au niveau du site
pilote
ce qui me plaît dans mon métier c'est
vraiment le côté relationnel
avec mes clients donc les planteurs et
industriels pour une très grande
majorité